un projet collectif c'est ce qui clôt la
période d'internât des jeunes de
l'académie des dalons la 10e promotion
de garçons deux derniers cas voulu faire
un travail d'introspection pour trouver
les bases pour l'écriture d'un spectacle
le message est clair fait pas comme ne
rentrent pas dans la galère une galère
qui ici est liée au décrochage scolaire
a décidé fait ces spectacles pas que les
jeunes ne passaient dans le même chemin
que nous de la galerie basculer molle
passé domench uniquement parce que dit
elle à gardena d'etion une injustice on
a senti médecins des façades en
viendrait pas que je n'y suis vue d'oeil
et de seneffe le théâtre que passe un
message via le tueront pas dedans on a
zappé le départ est école parce que
maintenant sans diplôme est longue et
plus rien et moi même mais même à passa
dans un conte la ville est très dur
l'écriture a mené à recréer l'intérieur
d'une école
ici tout se joue l'avenir mais également
cette possibilité de s'en sortir
au contraire des situations qui provoque
une vraie rupture sans retour comme l'a
vécu kanji denis ou encore thomas c
comprend les auges année vous mondial ça
ne vaut pas qu'ils décollent pas là
l'école comme ça ça ce point apple de
magana travail reçoit famille va
l'oublier ne veut pas et tombe dans le
young alliés telle ou telle pièce de
théâtre qu'on va jouer la laisse enfin
compte c'est pas les gêner dans la gale
et c'est plus d été si comme en deux et
ça très 16-2 l'école cesetti les salles
et bien ça parce qu'ils apprécient ou
commandités l'école est pas bon pas bon
pour commencer la fessée ceux là bas
même sera pénalisée aujourd'hui je n'ai
plus de la fois le plus coté à 2 un
concentré de france
passez un message commun passe de chad
dans ce spectacle parrainé par erick
isana du théâtre la cour a débuté par un
travail d'écriture puis il a fallu faire
vivre les textes pour enfin créer une
vraie mise en scène
outre les spectacles dans les t on tout
nous pousse à nous tous les acteurs de
danser dès que le théâtre toute lecture
et une petite joute dans l'écriture
c'était un peu dur parce qu'il fallait
voir que fall ont fait un texte et à
prométhée relire laver des choses des
bars boites documentaire ou que le texte
le texte c'est au texas aux mamans rien
toucher et m'a simplement travailler
autour de l'humain sur ce travail
d'acteur mise en scène
comment entrent et sortent ces quelques
mots comment vous aimez alésia non c'est
bien articuler bien faire comprendre
notre message surtout c'est ça
l'académie des dalles on veut redonner
de l'espoir à ces jeunes les remettre
sur les rails et cela passe évidemment
par une meilleure confiance en soi et en
ses qualités
ici le théâtre des livres des émotions
mais surtout des ambitions pour les
futurs et c'est ce message que veut
faire passer les académiciens ce projet
collectif sera proposé à de nombreux
collèges pour montrer l'importance du
parcours scolaire dans l'insertion
sociale
le message on sait leurs messages à eux
parce que c'est
des expériences vécues qui vont
retranscrire la jeunesse réunionnaise
dans l'occurrence sur les 83 collèges du
département à découvrir donc ce
spectacle qui se jouera dans le cadre
des journées européennes du patrimoine
au musée de villèle